[Applaudissements]
franchement les filles vous êtes
magnifique a gâté kenya si ça vous va
très bien c'est petit et vous aussi
isabelle valérie je vais déjà dit et non
plus le chiot le ya un côté wayne ont la
cote et les sondages il ya quatre
personnes très sympa ici une question
sur mon chevalet allons si c'est parti
je m'appelle marie christine déjà je
voudrais dire que j'aime beaucoup maxime
gagné parce que dans l'équipe c'est le
seul qui fait propre sinon j'avais une
question est ce que vous montrez
vraiment tout dans votre rubrique ou
filtrée vous un peu pour que vos
collègues ne finissent pas à l'asile
mais carrière c'est très attendu tous
les mercredis et c'est une excellente
question vu qu'on pose très souvent
marketing et je vais y répondre une
bonne fois pour toutes ce soir alors
évidemment que je filtre car le public
n'est pas prêt à tout voir maintenant ça
va vous surprendre mais contrairement
aux idées reçues j'essaie au maximum de
donner une image valorisante de mes
camarades par exemple vous trouvez
maxime propre et gentille mais et c'est
vrai que pendant les pauses
publicitaires il va serrer les mains
dans le public comme s'il était en
campagne électorale mais billy pas aussi
lisse que ça quand même petite
particularité il fait sa pub mail en
profite pour aussi pour descendre les
autres non
[Musique]
et frédéric vous avez
bah
un jour
demandez est ce que tu peux faire venir
mathieu j'ai appelé mathieu est ce que
tu peux aller tu mens quoi qu'il
comprend rien un jour un membre du
public me demande est ce que vous pouvez
faire venir mathieu c'est un truc à lui
dire chapelle mathieu et mathieu n'est
jamais venu nan je m'en fiche
ah oui ça fait très bien matthew goss
que c'est vrai immensee mais prévenu
cette jeune fille qui est toute mignonne
secrète où tu te dis lui faire un bisou
c'est ce que t'as pas envie qu'on soit
en noir à l'extérieur choix merci
beaucoup
la vérité envers cette opa sur la
seconde parce que je n'ai l'extrême et
je n'ai pas l'âme et je l'aurai un jour
là j'avais pas pu les voir ça
[Applaudissements]
je vous parlais avec moi en tout cas ça
normalement je ne le montre pas vrai
comme j'évite de montrer qu'en
jean-michel mais des coups de pression à
cyril en parlant tout seul à sa place
mais parce que je n'aime pas au courant
ça ça va changer ça vous savez pas c'est
quand vous lui faites une réflexion jean
michel et vénère me dit rien non par
contre dès que vous avez le dos tourné
il fait le bonhomme il s'invente un
dialogue dans sa tête
le mec il est bon pour la camisole de
force
vous allez voir à côté valérie elle fait
même plus attention
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi le problème
non non c'est j'aime beaucoup mais avec
mes valises et n'écoute même pas annoncé
imaginez pas tout les pumas elle c'est
un bruit de fond c'est horrible est
celle qui est la plus exposée canada ce
mec
alors pour bien de jean michel jarre
était aussi de passer les extraits qui
pourrait remettre en cause ses
brillantes interventions à l'antenne à
ce qu il y en à fait honnête si il ya
des bonnes interventions de la preuve
que le jour on avait reçu maître gims
voilà donc on mais pourquoi mettre 40
d'un coup et pas faire plusieurs albums
c'est pas plus rentable de faire plus un
symbole que 45 au mal pas mal marché bah
non c'est une bonne question
[Applaudissements]
elle est gentil quand même bien mais
très gentiment direct des choses que je
vais pas non plus d'indicateurs
quelqu'un je sais pas quoi en faire
et comme c'est dommage de gâcher je suis
dit que dorénavant j'avais rajouté une
micro rubrique l'anecdote la moins
intéressant de la semaine parce qu'après
tout tu te dis que si un chroniqueur a
tenu à le raconter
c'est qu'il trouvait sa digne d'intérêt
alors qui suis-je pour juger
il a été vu dans alerte à malibu qui
était venu david charvet incroyable j'ai
écouté sa chanson hier incroyable
j'écoutais un gentillet et c'est quoi ta
chance voulais c'était quoi déjà
non non tu m'embrasses nana dans bien
d'autres races
[Musique]
dion
je t'attendrai
vers les îles sont plus forts que shazam
et enrichir open la chanson avec son
[Applaudissements]
panel de chansons quoi ah ça c'est vrai
non vie voilà quoi pas de quoi samedi
soir parce que je vais là britney spears
parti qui est une soirée très
sympathique voulait pas venir avec moi
j'avais version pc tout à l'heure dans
des capsules à l'abri je vous propose
une soirée
ah oui arrive oui et donc alors je vous
dire je vais vous parler anglais pour la
première fois avec 10 titres game super
soit vous passez à la maison avant on
fait un before vous filent un débardeur
et touré doit lancer antoine hubert et
où on y va ensemble à un peu je présente
des potes et tout serait bien vu un
groupe on va là britney spears instant
dans les clichés du toulon veut on va
rigoler web à écouter essayer de joindre
samedi soir suis je toujours le bon nul
voilà mercy mercy corps
bien sûr tout cas c'est très sympa de
bobl faut le penser à moi parce qu'il y
en a d'autres à la madonna lady gaga
lady gaga ou alors ya aussi des choses
que je vais pas parce que ça a été trop
tendu en plateau ah ouais des moments on
va dire la vérité s'est rendu comme un
string non on rigole on rigole mais
parfois ça coince un peu
je sais pas si je me souviens mais la
semaine dernière mais si reed avait
remarqué quelque chose chez lui et il
avait dit à kelly très discrètement
comme d'habitude et ça le sniper il n'a
pas du tout aimé mais pas du tout nord
c'est pas le dessus
[Rires]
[Musique]
elle a désarmé
salut qu'à très long terme a dit m
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
dans les colonies
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça va mieux mais c'est vrai que ce
jour-là il est mal partout sauf dans
l'épisode est parmi les big c est tout
le sens plus j'ai mis le temps 15 jours
pour moi ma mamie passage à la main une
chose importante quand jean michel est
fâché contre si reina kelly
bizarrement il se prend surtout à kelly
[Rires]
et au passé elles en plus ce qu'il a dit
la semaine prochaine se montrerait aussi
extra
allez on passe tout objet danse donc
cette compilation des petits moments qui
ne peuvent pas se passer que dans tpm p
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les beaux tubes
[Musique]
si tu
deschamps ne prouve son plateau
échangeurs alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cet hiver nous devrions le véritable
retour ou marketing
et puis là d'origine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
énorme
le projet était prisé en dépit 0 rappelé
on n'a pas vraiment de souvenirs parce
qu'on voit un autre faire des shows et
lacan jours c'est hyper impressionnant
quand je revois aussi
ah oui ça prend fin que vous allez au
prix de bien après une course hippique
objets dangereux aussi pu mettre cyril
pendant l'émission paranormal déjà pour
son costume
parce que y'a des studios marvel qui ont
appelé votre veste de michou avec une
cape rouge a priori ils vont pas gardé
l'idée pour doctor strange du donc pour
le costume mais aussi pour la tête de c
est pendant le débrayage dana qui avait
vu des extraterrestres et qui pouvaient
se dématérialise une en relais dans
l'espace ou dans l'antarctique
now qu'elle ait jamais vous dire tu
regardes sncf bas les couilles
regardez bien la tête de cyril le mec
est pas bien alors poursuit cas mais il
déchire même des petits bouts de fiches
terme au passage préféré c'est quand
même essayer de faire une blague à nava
pas le calcul est alors s'il va se faire
tout petit tu comme s'ils avaient pris
la main dans le pot de confiture ses
quartiers dans le coma je me suis vue
sur la table en immersion de style je
suis parti dans la lumière et la
deuxième fois traitées en bien et
j'étais dans cet endroit qui est en fait
sans limite
blanc comme l'imam et c'est que de
l'amour est en fait quand en allant à
leur préservation
on n'a pas envie de revenir parce que
c'est
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est compliqué a dit mettez pmp faute
solides ont donné un série là un truc et
ce truc qui s'appelle jean-michel la
rocade doute et c'est toujours qu'il
peut compter sur lui si un ami fidèle
pourtant on va enfin comprendre le
secret de longévité dans cette émission
a
[Musique]
c'était un dîner organisé par des amis à
moi parce que j'étais comment dîner
presque parfait
au milieu c'est bien possible mais
surtout made in more than it bag
[Applaudissements]
de toutes les situations je me suis
fâché avec deux amis deux amis qui
veulent absolument s'enchaîner aux
grilles ya pas de candidat
selon une rumeur
[Applaudissements]
alors
une banda père il sait tout faire j'ai
un message de nicolas sarkozy thibault
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à toi qui ont
conscience merci merci bonjour me c'est
grâce à toi vous êtes fort vous savez si
vous êtes au dessus et hop voilà ou
pyramides ont démarré dès qu'on aime
notamment aux aidants c'est vrai là on
essaie l'alimentaire et après youtube ou
ya l'éléphant lorca et vous en êtes où
elle faisait les choses un moment
extrêmement ils ont l'éléphant lorsque
vous pouvez même dire que je suis le
pire je vous aimerai que jamais de la
vie jamais
j'en peux plus que c'est bien que les
mamies les magouilles ou non mais si
l'édile éléphants et tout j'ai dis pas
ça à cause de la trompe
non mais alors si vous nous reste une
personne qui est sur une autre émission
en fait et voilà parfois leur agi comme
ça mais remercie d'être bon il y avait
un peu plus doux mais comme la wii alors
commence quand la venue de maître gims
dans l'émission et vous allez voir quand
jean-michel fait une vanne la différence
flagrante entre une chroniqueuse
expérimentés comme valérie est un
chroniqueur ultra préfet degrés devinez
qui c'est
[Musique]
quand je vous remets
salut
[Musique]
jean ii
[Applaudissements]
ce moment la seule à le voir et
brusquement il sera une suite concrète
parce que j'ai pas vu une marche
tellement soins garder le match
regrettait les figures je me suis réuni
l'entente sévère qui a duré deux
semaines
et quand je me suis relevé le mec n'est
pas des chiens
[Musique]
c'est vrai que d'autres quoi
[Applaudissements]
mais samedi
bon camarade façon c est ce que tu
manteau ou tragédie ont fait un grand
concert mais où tout le monde attendait
sénia c'était à la tournée âge tendre et
tête de bois
[Musique]
min
depuis quatre ans
jamais
[Musique]
c'est la laisser linga temps la kiffe
laisser tuer encore faire un clip à gaja
passion
[Musique]
et au chili je dois tu es toi tu es
parti pour quinze membres
joli je te le dit un style
[Musique]
je
je te lis ton style
[Applaudissements]
internat et j'adore aussi vraiment
vraiment j'adore je vous êtes d'aurel
mais vous connaissez pas frappé jeudi
matin balle mais j'adore cette chanson
et j'adore cet artiste jean luc lemoine
ex
[Applaudissements]